no fue un intento para derrocar al
gobierno de Rusia sino para darle una
lección y preservar la existencia del
grupo Wagner
ha roto su silencio tras Haber puesto
fin a la rebelión de las estructuras
paramilitares en un mensaje de audio de
11 minutos
hemos demostrado una clase magistral
Como debería haber sido el 24 de febrero
de 2022 no teníamos el objetivo de
derrocar al régimen existente y al poder
legitimamente electo como se ha
mencionado muchas veces antes hemos dado
la vuelta para no derramar la sangre de
los soldados rusos
el jefe de la milicia privada dijo que
sus tropas lograron acercarse a 200
kilómetros de Moscú antes de decidir dar
la vuelta y regresar
quiero señalar que nuestra marcha de
Justicia
mostró muchas de las cosas de las que
hemos hablado series problemas de
seguridad dentro del país nosotros
bloqueamos todas las unidades militares
y las áreas en nuestro recorrido
se trata de un golpe directo a la
credibilidad de Vladimir Putin y uno a
gran escala en la disputa de gojin con
el Ministerio de defensa ruso
a pesar de que no demostramos ninguna
agresión se lanzó un ataque con misiles
contra nosotros y los helicópteros
hicieron lo mismo inmediatamente después
murieron unas 30 personas combatientes
de Wagner este incidente sirvió como
detonante que obligó al consejo de los
comandantes de Wagner para decidir que
tenemos que comenzar la marcha de
inmediato
Se desconoce desde donde privoying grabó
su mensaje así como cuando además sus
afirmaciones no pueden ser verificadas
aunque supuestamente se llegó a un
acuerdo que haría que prigollying se
trasladará a belarus aunque no se ha
podido confirmar si realmente llegó al
país o no O cuál será su estado
medios estatales rusos dicen que todo
sigue igual en varios centros de
concentración de Wagner pero el futuro
papel de pregollón y su grupo
paramilitar dentro y fuera de Ucrania
sigue siendo incierto